what's this dude wand ugh okay this is
Westham guys this is Weston coming for
some relations wedding after the hotel
what's up guys I need some relationship
advice dang bro serious at least no you
have here what do you do when you have a
great personality you can get any girl
you want will tell you these monkey
assault yeah that's a car scene them
back don't worry no no babies are in it
gang bro what do you do when you're
trying to get a girl and you can get off
with your president allottee you look
when you're wearing a hat
mmm you take that hat off Gang Gang Gang
Gang bald bald you know I'm saying it's
tough no totally most dudes don't kow
that's a style for them white people it
is an affliction not good not good it's
not good
let's just be real it's not good when
you're bald yeah so old it's like our
diabetes whoo I'm saying though
absolutely it's like a melt like it's
like something it's frowned upon will
milling around and if it happens it's
like very very frowned it's just
alarming it's like always milling in the
distance I mean if you bought wing
it's very frowned upon yeah in the white
community but I think bro I think first
of all if you you seem like an athletic
guy if you're like athletic goes better
with ball than not athletic
Amazon he's not athletic
he looks good billionaire ball but he
also had to be a billionaire to get any
[ __ ] puss probably you know a you
know a $25,000 year Jeff Bezos dude you
just said just a internet troll yeah no
I'm saying in a Chrysler 300 and I'm not
mad at the wig game these days we go to
a restaurant the student has a fantastic
wig and it's it's a way to get a
conversation started yeah and also
here's one thing that I thought about I
thought about coming out with some new
wigs because it's all
so like a fad that's been gone for so
long that it's almost due for a
resurgence you know I was watching some
crime show yesterday or something some
lady had a wig dude
and I was like oh hell yeah brah but
listen all but most black girls wear
wigs and their Joe yeah yeah that's a
good point you'll see a body wax
oh dude Armand there's one lady had a
[ __ ] champagne glass in know for sure
and it was like built into the style you
know I saw one with Sirius radio in
their hair it's great one lady had a
router
I remember [ __ ] getting white of a
signal wireless router I've seen her
around Santa Monica the other thing is
though I didn't know all black girls
wear wave cuz there's this pretty black
girls don't wear wigs well if they have
like long hair a lot of them have
extensions or legs a lot but this one
girl came in she liked dope red hair
next day she had green I was like damn
just spent all night dyeing her hair so
I think what goes good with a with a
girl is confidence you gotta have that
confidence so I'd love to see some nice
toupees on a man we see a man here
locally to have a toupee on a dead he
was gonna [ __ ] whee laughs whee laughs
that's not home to my guy you can't tell
the other we laugh dude that's not the
part no I'm saying he laughs we laugh
because he knows he's killing it he's
like and it's so obvious he'll show up
and that [ __ ] is just he'll what's up
one day here they put in a little shark
fin at the top and I love that because
you could take on a dance floor and be
that kind of shark on the dance floor
you know people tip their hats he tipped
his toupee to us who went how you doing
boys oh there it is there I'll say this
if you I think it one thing is you use
it as a motivation tool to safes to stay
physically fit because having no hair on
your head is but being physically fit I
think that kind of matches on a sexy
it's kind of sexy right secondarily UFC
logo yeah your head looks okay bro dude
if I lose my air bro I am never gonna
work again bro
I had it totally flat on the top yeah
it's just gonna get real awkward in a
couple years you know and so your Lego
piece yeah I'm gonna look like a [ __ ]
leg Lego might need to work on camera
let go of your bank account but but with
this dude also you could do the LeBron
James spray paint that [ __ ] looks like
a Pittsburgh Steeler you know I'm saying
also the other thing you can do is you
can just kind of go the professor Eck's
route get wheelchair get real skinny I
think there's different styles that you
like just spin ideas out here I'm chair
chin has low hair or no hair I don't
even know Jenn are you going bald buddy
this is though is it yeah for sure but
do you feel uncomfortable cuz I feel
like this look fit to you do you feel
uncomfortable I like it when it's short
no like it when it's long so well pay
for that dude if you can grow facial
hair I think looks good but here's the
thing you see is the the bird's nest on
the side like an old man ditch that yeah
cut I'll have it all shaved
drop that nice little bit that beard
hitter look like Zac Brown Band and
start [ __ ] girls down dude who else
is losing hair in here no you losing
sums you couldn't get any more hairy
Derek your shits getting a little thin
in it black guys it's a tight style yeah
and Derek yeah and also darica will have
long hair sometimes he doesn't really
your hair doesn't really seem like it
does it if you said if do you think
about your hair like but I can still
grow it out long but do you think about
it a lot like does it no that doesn't
bother me
there's my four hams does it do you for
him I've never thought about it ah man
bro go let it go let it go out okay
you're growing up heads your attitude
now that's a good attitude guys aren't
like that but here's the thing you don't
have to worry about his girl cuz she's
blindfolded yeah so now you look good
again yeah she definitely not I'm gonna
let you go today
but now one thing I'll say is this
though a lot of it is your attitude
towards it as well because it's but
interesting because zoom in I started
noticed my hair is getting thin in the
front and the top is thick pro-roh but I
noticed it right so then in my mind it
starts getting to be a bigger thing and
then I start getting paranoid I start
wearing hats I start like you know
talking to people and look another
direction I start doing things that seem
obtuse for humans damn yeah yeah dude
I'm not joking I know dude doing this
movie training thing I was like oh maybe
I'll wear a bandana like I just start
thinking of things so then a lot of it
is odd then I'm fearful my confidence is
going so then it's like I'm trying to
talk to him find in the bushes you know
what I'm saying I'm not even a peeping
tom I'm just a guy who just has their
concern now you're a catfish yeah now
yeah now I'm Nev Lieberman or whatever
that guy's name is Nev Schulman yeah
do you like to open a bandana though
yeah the small one and tie it and get
belonging out the back but with you know
dachshund eggs
Haim bro no it's a bummer with no hair
on the top but you have here on the top
I have here on the top but also then you
know there's surgeries you can get these
days where you get some other taking off
but for you I don't know probably do
that man I think I would just get a nice
round head dude yeah I would just
[ __ ] rock with the round head and
have confidence try glasses if you want
to try some different yeah but but also
dress nice but also you got to ditch the
side the birdsnest dude that's number
one let me show it to old and no one no
one's attract that [ __ ] yeah didn't you
look like you're going bald whereas now
you look like you're making more of a
choice like it was like you control it
bro like you control it
your father times your barber yeah but
you control it dude yeah get it [ __ ]
shave tight to the side and dude I also
just got my hair cut at a casino in
Biloxi Mississippi other day and had the
absolute [ __ ] worst haircut of my
life really cuz you look exactly the
same
really yep thanks man yep alright well
good luck man
oh god that boy he's fantastic good to
have you back man good to be back I need
to take a break from the Hollywood Life
and join the peasants down here yeah man
well it's a nice down here and now it's
good to see everyone everyone's doing
well
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]